[Music]
when a girl named Sylvie and her family
of creatures needs a new home this stage
comes to life
it's always a dancer and got into
theater and then I decided to make a
puppet and like all puppeteers you have
this moment where you put a puppet on
and show it to someone and Magic happens
the play is called go home tiny monster
the boston-based gotta bees production
is a mix of puppetry live action theater
music and wordless joy the family
production is part of a boundary pushing
Chicago International Puppet Theater
Festival the Puppet Theater turns out to
be a a type of performance where uh the
the if it's a little figurine or if it's
a marionette or if it's a hand puppet or
whatever it is it'll it can take these
stories which are in many ways much
bigger than humans and embody them in a
way that's that's very immediate those
performances have pushed puppetry into
the modern era there are many
traditional puppets performing here at
the festival Chicago but some shows are
pushing the limits on what it means to
be a puppet and a puppeteer
the Finish play Invisible lens seeks to
humanize a global migrant crisis the duo
on the stage are not actors their bodies
are the set on which miniature puppets
carry out their hopeful often tragic
Journeys the bodies are contact with the
world it's the way to create
[Music]
connection to ourselves the surrounding
that we live in and also to other people
so without
seeing bodies touching bodies being
around bodies we don't have empathy we
cannot understand other people
in the French puppetry play Anywhere a
live actress portrays Antigone daughter
of Oedipus who is played by a marionette
made of ice dangling on 15 meter long
strings who over the course of the play
melts into Oblivion what makes it
special as a puppeteer and as a builder
is I make a new puppet every show and I
get to watch this new character finish
their their life in front of all of us
it's quite moving and meaningful to me
the poetic journey of the doomed
marionette demonstrates that after
centuries of evolution of the art
puppetry can still melt a heart John
hendren Al Jazeera Chicago